[Musique]
j'ai récupéré des des draps des choses
demande à saint-léger-en-yvelines marie
claude a ramené des draps et différents
tissus donné par le voisinage
le petit groupe de bénévoles de
l'association over the blues créer du
matériel pour le personnel soignant
c'est très important il ya des gens qui
ont besoin d'aidé s'ils roulent aux et
c'est très important de pouvoir mais ça
ne marche que si on est nombreux pour
pouvoir avoir chacun quelque chose à
faire et parce que chaque blouson mais
au moins trois heures pour les coudre
simplement
après ça va il faut traiter de clichy
c'est à dire leur passé il faut le
préparer tout ça c'est très long dans
cet atelier les bénévoles découpe chaque
morceau de tissu grâce à des patrons qui
serviront à créer les surblouse les
manches le buste sans oublier les
élastiques tout doit être prêt pour
faciliter la couture ici effectivement
on découpe tout on assemble on a des
élastiques over the blues man a passé
quelques mètres moi j'en avais aussi du
vitrage à la maison donc on prépare tout
après les filles qui y poussent donc
envoie un sms pour me dire est-ce qu'on
peut passer à la salle à quelle heure
elles viennent chercher des blues à
coudre et elle me les ramènent quelques
jours après une fois les pièces
constituées elles sont repassées est
envoyé aux soignants mari de robillard
est une des co gérante à l'initiative du
projet elle s'occupe de la logistique
entre les couturières bénévoles
on est tout seul bénévole et qui allons
vivre et déjà plus de sept îles ont
vraiment je remercie tous ces bénévoles
qui est vraiment reçu machine incroyable
des blues qui ont rejoint les hôpitaux
et les centres villes et noah pour les
soignants qui sont en première ligne
face aux cours aux navires russes